décrocher le titre de meilleur ouvrier
de france l'ambition de sophie mathieu
esthéticienne à dijon elle a délaissé
quelques jours son institut pour venir
ici à auxerre participer aux sélections
nationales du congo c'est une façon de
montrer notre façon de travailler
personnellement je cherche toujours
j'essaie de de rechercher la perfection
médaille autour du cou
elena peter a décroché le titre de
meilleur ouvrier de france en 2011
pourra pour candidate lauréate et
modèles la voici lé jury pour la
première fois à l'excellent satire et et
les choses rares en général attire
également donc en france pour l'instant
il ya 35 mof l'esthétique
donc c'est pas beaucoup donc
c'est un titre que fin c'est un rêve
pour certains noms comme sophie elles
sont une quarantaine en compétition dans
la catégorie esthétique et arts du
maquillage
toutes doivent rivaliser de technique
mais aussi d'originalité de créativité
et d'innovation
[Musique]
souvent il ya des a priori sur
l'esthétique effectivement mais on il
faut passer à priori là il ya plus en
plus d'essai ty sienne maintenant qu'ils
développent le bien-être la relaxation
le spa peut se diriger dans le
maquillage en la prothésie ongulaire
qu'en fait c'est un domaine qui
contrairement à ce qu'on entend souvent
n'est absolument pas boucher il a du
travail en esthétique on peut être
formatrice on peut être prof peut être
manager on peut partir dans le marketing
il ya plein de possibilités travailler
en labo après un bts
donc tout dépend en fait de la formation
vers laquelle on se dirige
à quelques centaines de mètres l'un des
nombreux instituts de beauté de la ville
massages relaxation épilation le client
peut passer ici la journée entière les
rendez vous s'enchaînent les uns après
les autres
la société est en plein essor elle
emploie 17 salles dont une est dans une
période positive parce qu'on est sur le
concept de la beauté globale à l'on peut
aussi bien faire de l'esthétique cas
soins corps soins visage épilation ou
autres aussi bien la coiffure ou de
l'onglerie donc le fait que l'on puisse
dans un même lieu trouvé tous tous ces
soi nous ça fonctionne très bien
jouanny son école privée d'esthétique la
seule dans l'yonne agréé par l'éducation
nationale clairborne en est la
directrice du capc bts elle forme chaque
année une cinquantaine de jeunes filles
aux métiers du soin et de la beauté des
élèves très jeune aux parcours et aux
motivations différentes
c'est un métier de fille généralement
mais bon les hommes viennent souvent en
ce moment et bah j'aime bien esthétique
tout simplement en contact avec le
client puis aussi le fait que ça change
contre tout le temps en train de faire
la même chose
la plupart d'entre elles voudrait
ensuite se diriger vers les métiers du
maquillage pas la voie la plus facile
mais là encore tout est question de
motivation
il ya du travail évidemment pour elle
les meilleures celles qui excelle dans
le domaine
il y a de la place pour ba celles qui
sont au top en stage elle trouve
toujours du travail à l'issue des stages
est si elles sont parfaites
certaines quittent la région certaines
ouvrent leur entreprise également donc à
elles deux
de faire leur place dans le métier
l'école affiche fièrement 100 % de
réussite aux examens l'an dernier et en
2016 mais pour l'insertion
professionnelle ces jeunes filles
devront privilégier le bien-être la
relaxation ou le naturel plutôt que les
salons d'esthétique classique qui
tendent à disparaître